I wonder if you meant but these things
do you remember I showed you these for
example that one of the right is or just
just have a look at my grid squares okay
this is two and that five so this
rectangle over here is a way of
representing ten it's just one way of
visualizing if they differ lots of ways
to visualize this is one of them if you
have a look on the Left do you remember
this was my argument for why a plus B in
fragments I'll put the brackets times a
plus B which of course is just a plus B
all squared
this was my reason for arguing why it's
not just a squared plus B squared from
the diagram how would you argue that
it's not just a squared plus b square
what would you say where is the a
squared it is this guy over here alright
and where's the beat where if this guy
over here you can tell because they're
squares right and what I'll miss you is
that this is a B isn't and you've got
another a B so that's why there's that
to a being hanging out there in the
middle okay now I want to call your mind
back to this because this is going to be
main instrument for explaining this
process of a huge so pick up your pencil
now if you've got one pen will do if
you've got alternative but I want to
return to this this is the first thing
we were trying to factorize before x
squared plus 5x or 6 I want to draw this
and see what's going on I'd love you to
draw a with me you've got grid squares
as well so here's how I'm going to try
and visualize it keeping in mind that X
is a variable it's a pro new rule it
really could be anything but I can't I
can't draw anything on the page so I'm
just going to pick a length so I'm just
going to make this let's make this
something like seven units high okay
now I've made it look like it's seven
units but I'm going to call this X so
you really could draw it as bigger as
small as you like but this will be a
good size will be able to fit everything
else on our diagram if it's about seven
times
so it does X then to make x squared I'm
going to draw a square that has that as
one of the signs I've drawn that into
side I guess I'll draw one across one
two three four five six seven like so if
that X as well I can complete this shape
and this shape is a way of representing
x squared are you happy with that
so no counting all right now that takes
squared I want to figure out how am I
going to represent the rest of this
expression up there the rest of this
quadratic expression well the next step
is 5 X 5 X 5 times X so I have lots of
ways I could do this but I think a
common-sense way is to draw another line
that is X hi what will I attach it to to
make a rectangle that's 5x yeah I'll go
5 across something like that so this
rekt Jake rectangle is a representation
of 5x there's X square this 5x the last
thing I need is sips now 6 doesn't look
like it has to be a rectangle but again
if I want to I could represent it as 1
because 6 is 6 times 1 isn't it 6 is 6
times 1 so therefore I'm just going to
draw 1 2 3 4 5 6 and 1 just to make it
clear I'm just going to make these use
it a little obvious so this guy over on
the right so I hope you can see around
my big head that guy's 6 ok so you've
just drawn x squared plus 5x plus 6 okay
he comes the kid we were thinking of two
numbers we wanted to break apart 5 into
like two numbers that add up to 5 like 1
& 4 or 0 & 5 or whatever okay we chose 2
& 3
let me show you why we chose 2 & 3 if
five adds up so two and three add up to
five the reason why that's useful is
because I could write it like this
let me move a little bit do you agree
that this is still X square plus 5x plus
6 I just sort of split it apart those
numbers be close so that's the case how
would I draw this okay well have a look
we've got two parts that are the same I
apologize that you can't do this but you
guys will be able to draw the rest of it
a bit quicker than I can anyway so you
can see get rid of this guy over here
there's my x squared and there's my six
so far so good but instead of 5x I've
broken it into two so what would that
look like well I started drawing 5x by
drawing this sky which was X hi so how
will I draw two X instead of 5x I'll
just go to a cross you're getting a hang
of it that guy there is 2x
what about 3x okay so I'm going to go
three across let me move this guy
shuffle it over a little bit so some
space okay you can try this too
okay now we've been playing some games
with these shapes before right like at a
ground you can shuffle around you can
make new things you can visualize okay
remember where I'm headed
you actually know the answer this
question already I'm trying to head
towards not a some lot of products
something turns something else in other
words I'm trying to make a rectangle out
of this one rectangle I with the n-type
whoops Vale's antigen okay so I'm gonna
show you how I get there onto the second
let me add relieve subspace there we go
okay here we go so I'm trying to make
one rectangle out of all of these it's
not that hard to do
remember how they're both or one two
three they're all X hi that means I can
do this can you can you draw that see it
appearing in its new rectangle can you
draw that for me okay
you just factorized it that's what
factorizing means is putting together
these objects have a look at this new
object on the left it's X hi how wide is
it look carefully how wide is it it's X
and then it's two more isn't it
look sorry if X plus two right so this
rectangle is X outside of X plus two but
I'm not done yet
I've got this guy as well where am I
going to put him where was his hips
now I can't just move him like that I
can do that okay but if I do that I'm
kind of stuck you see the six on the end
he's got nowhere to go
no way to fit so instead of just
shuffling him over to the left
watch carefully either I'm going to move
him over here you go
do you see I can do that do you see why
I can do that
why can I just turn it because it's X hi
now it's X why don't you see that do you
see that so now that means what can I do
with this guy over here this six do you
see right fit and why the two numbers we
had to think of had to multiply to give
C G Zn 2 times 3 right now just just
think just rewind a little bit suppose
let's let's do this again suppose I
that's not normal
suppose I chose the wrong pair of
numbers 2 & 3 are the only numbers you
can choose right so I'm going to break
apart this 5x I'm going to break it
apart instead into 1x that's 1 X isn't
it and he is 4x it's still the same
expression
do you agree it's still equal but look
what happens when I try when I try to
put this guy's shift the robe up like
that I can still twist this guy around
and fit in where it belongs
but now look see that gap I've got see
this guy over here I'm sorry see this
guy over here
it doesn't six the six that I've got
unlike this one it's just right so this
is why two and three are perfect and one
at four are not this is why you're
trying to get them to add up to five
because five is your building block this
is the thing you're cutting off you can
cut into two and three or one and four
or whatever you like why do they need to
multiply can you tell me again what's
the shape reason why it's could you try
to fill in over here a rectangle that
will fit your asked nicely if it doesn't
fit just nicely you're kind of stuck
you're like oh sorry six you're just
going to have to hang out on the end
it's a factor I'd you see what I mean so
when you're searching for this pair of
numbers you're adding them up because
this shape is what your dissected that
this is where you're cutting up you're
multiplying to give that number on the
end because you're trying to do this
this think here see that if they don't
multiply you can't make a nice rectangle
and that's why you're searching okay